this makes me so happy
she's never had a reaction like that for
me and it's happened like a few times
they're back
yep
the kardashians just dropped the first
footage from their new hulu reality
series titled what else the kardashians
can you believe this is day one
literally this is insane
i love us
and it looks like fans are gonna get a
closer look at the moment travis barker
proposed to courtney back in october in
the trailer which was released on monday
court's momager kris jenner gets
emotional and gives the push founder a
big hug after saying yes to the blink
182 drummer and kim who is currently in
the middle of a divorce from her third
husband kanye west makes a joke at her
own expense
this makes me so happy
she's never had a reaction like that for
me and it's happened like a few times
travis pops up a few times and it looks
like he may have a pretty big presence
in the new series noticeably absent from
the clip scott disick court's ex and the
father of her three children who was a
crucial part of the family's prior show
keeping up with the kardashians i mean i
think you just gotta figure out really
what's important to you at the end of
the day of course he was there for all
of life's biggest moments and gave us
comedic relief like this
whether it's sir disick
lord disick
count disick becoming royal is really
gonna get the respect that i deserve
like i don't need to be walking around
like i'm some peasant i need to be
walking around like royalty and this
auntie chris it's me it's todd cranes
fans will just have to wait until the
show premieres april 14th on hulu to see
if scott makes an appearance but when it
comes to court and travis a source
recently told et that the two are deep
in wedding planning adding that they are
so in love that they are open to the
idea of having children together and
growing their family
i love you
[Music]
of course the 42 year old reality star
is already mom to 12 year old mason
nine-year-old penelope and
seven-year-old reign so let's get the
names you are
penelope mason mason what's your name
rain
yeah
and yes right
as for the 46 year old musician he
shares two teams with his ex shayna
mogler 18 year old landon and 16 year
old alabama put 30 in my chop and then i
turned him to a hug came a long way from
pre-k and eating lunchables and last
week shayna told et that if her kids pop
up on the kardashians reality series
she's all for it
i won't be tuning in
however
um you know i think it's fine if you
know this is an opportunity that they
want to be a part of and you know my
main concern is always you know my my
children are my first priority and you
know that's one thing that you know
travis and i you know do agree on it's
probably the only thing we agree on but
you know our children come first and
their happiness and as long as you know
the kardashians are good to my kids you
know that's all that matters to me as a
mom you know as long as they're happy
and then you know that's that's the key
[Music]
you